The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi.
I'm Jocelyn, and we're going to
go over fall 2009, exam 1,
problem number 3.
With every question, we want to
make sure we read the full
problem first. So answer the
following questions about the
difluoro-iodate ion.
Draw a three-dimensional
representation of the
molecular geometry around the
central atom, not simply the
Lewis structure.
Show all atoms and bonds
between them.
Because this part seems pretty
separate from the rest of
them, we're going to
start with that.
So we have a difluoro-iodate
ion.
It has a positive charge.
And it asks us to draw the
molecular geometry in a 3D
representation, and not
just Lewis structure.
However, to do the molecular
geometry in 3D, we need to
know the Lewis structure.
So we're going to
start with that.
To draw the Lewis structure,
we first need to figure out
which atom is the
central atom.
And it's always a good idea to
do that by looking at the
relative electronegativities.
As we know, fluorine is the most
electronegative element
in the periodic table, and so
that's probably not going to
be in the middle.
Therefore, iodine, being the
less electronegative, is going
to be in the middle,
and it will have
fluorines on either side.
This is our rough sketch of
the molecular geometry.
Not too important right now.
Next we need to know how many
electrons we have. Iodine has
seven valence electrons,
fluoride has seven valence
electrons, and we have a
positive charge, so we know
that we're missing one.
And that gives us
20 electrons.
Now that we know how many
electrons we have to work
with, we need start
filling them in.
I always start with the
outer electrons.
Those are usually, hopefully,
the most electronegative, and
therefore, the most likely to
have the octet rule satisfied.
Also, if you remember, fluorine
is in the second row,
and therefore needs to have
the octet rule satisfied.
Iodine is a little bit lower in
the periodic table, so the
octet rule isn't as important.
It can have an extended octet
if we need it to.
So we will work with
iodine second.
Let's start out with satisfying
the octet rule for
the fluorine, putting first the
seven valence electrons
that the fluorines brought
themselves, and then noticing
that each needs to share one
from iodine, so that we have a
full octet.
So each has one bond
with iodine.
We've used 8 electrons,
or 8 per fluorine.
So we have a total of 16.
We have 4 left, and
we're going to put
those on the iodine.
Counting up how many electronics
are around iodine,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, we see
that the octet rule is also
satisfied for iodine.
This is looking like a pretty
good Lewis structure.
Now, just to make sure it's
really good, we're going to
look at the formal charge.
So if you recall, the formal
charge is the number of
valence electrons that the
element usually has, and minus
the number of unshared
electrons, and
the number of dots.
So this sum subtracted from
the valence electrons will
give us the formal charge.
Looking at the fluorine, we have
seven valence electrons.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6 unpaired, and
one bond to the fluorine.
So that gives us a formal
charge of 0.
The same goes for the
other fluorine.
So I guess its formal
charge is 0.
Now for the iodine, we have--
I'm going to do the formal
charge down here--
it again has 7 valence
electrons, usually.
We have 4 unshared electrons,
and 2 bonds.
That gives us a formal
charge of plus 1.
Because we have a charged
species here, the full
molecule has a plus 1 charge.
There's no way we cannot have
a net formal charge.
Right?
We need to have a net formal
charge of plus 1.
And it makes sense that that
formal charge is on the least
electronegative atom.
So this looks like
the right Lewis
structure for our purposes.
One more thing that you might
want to write down.
I'm not sure if points were
taken off from this.
But technically, if you have a
charged species, put brackets
around your Lewis structure,
and put the net
charge on the outside.
This is not, however, our
final answer, right?
This is the Lewis structure.
But the question asks for the
molecular geometry to be
represented.
So if we remember how we
determine molecular geometry,
we need to look at the number of
electron domains around the
essential atom.
So we're going to move over
here, and I'll redraw our
Lewis structure.
And remember, an electron
domain can be either an
electron pair, or a bond.
So we see that iodine has
4 electron domains.
And if we remember our skeletal
geometry, we know
that that's tetrahedral.
Thus, to draw this in a more 3D
fashion, we might want to
say that one of the electron
pairs is here, one of the
electron pairs is over here,
and then we have a fluorine
coming out of the board, and a
fluorine going into the board.
We didn't really go
over how to do
three-dimensional drawings.
So as long as you show something
like, you know the
fluorines will be an angle, not
straight from the iodine,
and that the electrons be on the
other side, something to
that effect.
A little bit more detailed than
just a Lewis structure,
was what Professor Sadoway was
looking for in this problem.
And that would be your answer.
And for this one especially, I'd
say it's important to box
your final answer.
Because you hopefully would
have figured out the Lewis
structure, but this is not
the correct answer.
So you always want to
signify what answer
you want to be graded.
Part B says, name the type of
hybrid orbitals that the
central atom forms. So we are
almost all the way to
answering this question, so
I'll put it down here.
Remember, hybrid
orbitals are--
we have hybrid orbitals, because
we can't really say
what orbitals exactly are
bonding to which atoms. We
want to have 4 equivalent
orbitals for
this system, right?
We have 4 electron domains,
so we want 4
equivalent bonding orbitals.
And from our talks earlier
in the lectures about
hybridization, we know that if
we want 4, we take 1S and 3P,
and that gives us the
hybridization of the SP3.
if we only had 3 electron
domains, it would be SP2,
because we only use
3 orbitals.
And the number of orbitals that
go into the hybrid is the
number of orbitals
you will get out.
So we know that our
hybridization is SP3.
And that goes along with the
fact that our shape is
tetrahedral.
Now we need to name
the molecular
geometry of this molecule.
so we already have the molecular
shape and the kind
of spacial arrangement
is tetrahedral.
However, when we're naming the
molecular geometry, electron
pairs no longer matter.
So for part C, tetrahedral is
our skeletal geometry, right?
It shows us our special
arrangement.
The molecular geometry is
ignoring those electron pairs.
So it is called bent when
we only have 2 bonds.
And I think about that because
in spectroscopy and ways that
are used to study molecules,
you can't see the electron
clouds very well.
So they could only see the
iodine and the two fluorines,
thus looking like a
bent structure.
So hopefully you're sticking
with me here, because this
problem has a lot of parts.
And we're going to move
on to part D now.
Part D asks, is difluoro-iodate
polar or
nonpolar, and explain.
If you put down polar or
nonpolar and did not explain,
we assume you guessed, and you
didn't get any points.
Explaining shows that you know
why, and you understand the
concepts behind this,
and thus deserved
points on this problem.
So there's two different
parts of this problem.
First, to have a polar molecule,
you need to have
polar bonds.
So I would first ask myself,
are the bonds polar?
We have a difference of
electronegativity that you can
look up on your periodic table
and know is not negligible.
And so yes.
A difference in
electronegativity signifies
that our bonds are polar.
However, not all molecules
that have polar bonds are
themselves polar, right?
if we have spacial symmetry,
those polar bonds
could cancel out.
So now we need to make sure,
is the molecule polar?
And for that, we need
to have answered the
first questions correctly.
Right?
We need to know that this is
not a linear structure.
If this was a linear structure,
those polar bonds
would be geometrically
symmetric, and
cancel each other out.
But we all are very smart, and
we got this part C right.
We know that we have
a bent structure.
Thus, I'll rewrite
this over here.
We know that if we draw in our
polarity vectors, we can
realize that we'll have a net
dipole pointing down.
So the answer to this is yes,
because of the difference in
the electronegativity,
and because
of the spacial asymmetry.
If you said both of
those things, you
would get full credit.
If you said one or
the other, you'd
probably get part credit.
But knowing to look at these
two things shows that you
fully understand what it means
to have molecular polarity.
All right.
So now we're going to
move to part E.
This part is changing gears a
little bit, so if you didn't
quite understand the
first part, you can
still try this one.
Part E, again, what is the
question asking us?
Determine the maximum wavelength
of electromagnetic
radiation capable of breaking
the IS bond.
So we need to find the maximum
wavelengths which corresponds
to the minimum energy.
Right?
Because we have e equals
hc over over lambda for
electromagnetic radiation.
We're trying to figure out the
lowest energy of photon that
will break the IF bond.
Now, what are we given to
answer this question?
We're given the energy of the
homogeneous fluorine-fluorine
bond, is 160 kilojoules
per mole.
And the energy of the
homogeneous iodine-iodine bond
is 150 kilojoules per mole.
And in order to find the
wavelength that will break the
IS bond, we need to know the
energy of the IS bond.
Right?
That's what we're working
towards in this problem.
So given the homogeneous
energies, do we have a
relationship that will
help us determine the
energy of the IS bond?
If you recall, in lecture 9,
Professor Sadoway went over
the Pauling formula for
determining a heterogeneous
bond energy from the homogeneous
bond energies, and
the electronegativity.
So I'll just write
that up here.
The Pauling formula is, in a
generic form, the energy of an
AB bond equals the square root
of the product of the
homogeneous bond energies plus
a constant times the
difference between the
electronegativities squared.
And I just said what all
of these terms mean.
Because even if you had this on
your equation sheet in the
test or something, a lot of
people wrote this down, and
then used it incorrectly.
So it's really important to know
not only what equations
you have, but especially what
each of the terms in the
equations mean.
So we're given the homogeneous
bond energies, and we have a
periodic table, or some other
resource, that has the
elecronegativities.
Next step is to plug in the
numbers and find the energy of
the IF bond.
So we have the square root
of 150 kilojoules plus.
And the exact values you get for
the electronegativity may
vary, depending on the source.
But they'll be close
enough, and
relatively, probably very--
the difference between them
will be very similar.
So don't worry if your
numbers were a little
different than mine.
So we wrote all that out,
and plugging it into the
calculator, you get that the IF
bond has an energy of 323
kilojoules per mole.
Now that we've found the energy
of the IS bond, are we
done with the problem?
You have an answer.
You might be ready to move
on to the next question.
However, this isn't what the
question is asking us, right?
We are asked for the maximum
wavelength that can break a
bond of that energy.
So we need to go back to our
energy relation to our
wavelengths.
And we know that the wavelength
equals hc over the energy.
Now here's where some people
tripped up a little bit.
You have a value
for the energy.
h and c are constants.
And you find the lambda.
However, if you plugged that all
in, your answer would be
6.15 times 10 to the
negative 31 meters.
Some people, that was the
answer that they found.
And it makes sense.
You have an energy, you have
some constants, and you can
get your lambda.
However, if you think about
it, does this wavelength
actually make sense?
The gamma ray radiation has a
wavelength of about 10 to the
negative 17.
That's very, very,
very energetic
electromagnetic radiation.
So this is 14 magnitudes
smaller than gamma ray
radiation, and it just doesn't
make sense for a bond energy
of this much.
Plus it doesn't--
it just-- you should look at the
answer you get, and try to
be comfortable with if it
makes sense or not.
So where people got tripped
up, is in the units.
We found Pauling's formula gives
you the bond energy in
kilojoules per mole.
However, if you look at Planck's
constant, it has
units of joules time seconds.
The speed of light is in
meters per second.
And you want lambda in meters.
To make everything or cancel
out, that means we want the
energy to be in joules.
Not joules per mole, because
we're looking at the
wavelength of one
photon, right?
We're looking at the energy of
one photon to break this bond.
So we want the energy of the
bond, not per mole of bonds,
but just of one bond.
So instead of just having this
equation, we want to have put
in h times c over 323, change
it to joules, and then
multiply by--
sorry, moles are on
the bottom, 1 mole
and Avogadro's number.
And Planck's constant of the
speed of light, you should
have on your equation sheet, or
somewhere else, some other
resource that you have. You
don't need to memorize those
in most cases.
If you remembered to divide by
Avogadro's number, you got 3.7
times 10 to the negative 7
meters, which equals 370
nanometers.
And if we recall, the light we
can see is in the 400 to 700
nanometer range.
So this puts us in ultraviolet
radiation, which makes sense
that it would take that much
energy to break a bond.
The other problem some people
had was forgetting to convert
from kilojoules to joules.
That would still give you
a physical answer.
But again, I can't stress
unit cancel out enough.
So make sure you know that since
your Planck's constant
is in joules, you want
to make sure you have
joules on the bottom.